luis castillo he said after he had a
slow start last time out that he and
catcher tucker barnhart weren't quite on
the same page in the first inning the
second ending on they were outstanding
and the first two have reached for the
diamondbacks so two on and no outs four
is drubal cabrera
lifted up and it knocks it into the gap
here comes pathan smith cole calhoun
will stop at third
and the diamondbacks strike first get
him early
a lot of times guys that rely on a
straight changeup and zach gallon is
right in the same mold as luis castillo
it takes you an inning or so to get the
right split between your pitches to feel
that fastball coming out of your hand as
opposed to the changeup coming out of
your hand on that change up grip and now
you've got two on for david peralta
on the ground and by joey votto calhoun
comes in an rbi for peralta
and it's two nothing diamondbands i
stand corrected 12 first inning runs for
louise castillo keep it moving i love it
hit it off the end of the bat but hit it
in a good spot past joey botto
just out of his reach into right field
for an rbi base hit first four have
reached two runs in still no outs a
chance for carson kelly down
right to the shortstop suarez india
turns it
cabrera comes in and it's three-nothing
diamondbacks
escobar slid in safely at second base
we're ahmed now
swinging a miss
fastball in
seemed to have some light but the
diamondbacks draw first blood as they
place three and the reds grab their
backs zach gallon an encouraging return
from a hairline fracture in his right
forearm against the a's at chase field
last tuesday through all of his pitches
with no uh restrictions whatsoever
juarez who uh has been struggling at the
plate linger holds it first swinging a
miss and there's the gallon changeup for
his first strikeout changeup is so
effective especially if that hitter is
expecting a fastball at the plate allen
had missed with a couple of curveballs
if you're a neo hey eugenio suarez
you're probably thinking okay he's gonna
go back to the fastball
and then he drops that change up in
there for strike three two down for
vatto
flipped out to left field peralta near
the warning track and he's got it we've
played one in cincinnati ohio and the
diamondbacks lead the reds three nothing
there we go to the top of the second
inning three nothing diamondbacks lead
luis castillo is back to work
swing and a miss and down on strikes
nick heath
and there's one away here in the second
inning
there he goes down
looking
three straight strikeouts for castillo
cole calhoun now
bears down against the k three on the
inning four on the outing the reds need
some runs early still
it'll be as drupal cabrera number three
hitter in the diamondbacks lineup 3-2 is
rocketed backhand pick on his hip bottom
underhand shovel castillo on the cover
another well struck ball by cabrera
joey does it does a nice job of keeping
his hands away from his body and
catching that ball away castillo does a
great job of
bouncing off that mound
he got cabrera to ground out to start
the inning
walk hit batter walk they're loaded one
out for ahmed
fisted in the air shallow left hard
charge in by winker out races suarez
extends the club and makes the catch
spectacular play by a eugenio suarez and
breaking from third was peralta he's
forced to race back and everyone's still
aboard
nobody able to come across
[Music]
well that was an outstanding play
by henry suarez and you could see
winker has no chance to get there and
suarez makes a fantastic play so now
with one out remaining to get out of
this bases loaded jam nick heath
left-handed hitter they go 3-2 grounded
motto
handles foot race close play in vado
pessim
and luis castillo
able to wiggle off the hook we go to the
bottom of the third in cincinnati luis
castillo will stand in pitcher on
pitcher over four this year
there's a ground ball past the third
baseman cabrera castille turns he's not
satisfied with one take two young man
the double for the pitcher
well maybe there is something to be
the bat waggle
nice swing on a breaking ball and
[Applause]
[Music]
most of the times you do not see a third
baseman hugging the line when a pitcher
is swinging in the baton
as the bourbon cabrera cannot get to
that ball and la
segundo
so runners at first and third now
back-to-back hits here and tyler naked
when they hit her all of a sudden the
tide runs to the plate grounded right
side
pirouette escobar
and david smith recovers castillo scores
winker safe arrival to second base the
reds are on the board it's three to one
we talked about a difference in our
approach
this year as opposed to last year and
you can see naquin
with a productive out not the most
sensational play
but it's a very effective play
puts a run on the board
we go to the bottom of the force still
3-1 d-backs two on two out kyle farmer
is fly to center
smoked over short left field base hit
the wave is on they'll challenge peralta
his throw in
cut off a safe slide as the helmet flies
for jonathan india and kyle farmer
connects on an rvi base knock the reds
within one well kyle farmer coming up
with a big
hanging breaking ball right there farmer
does a nice job
go back to tucker barnhart coming up
with the bunt putting the runner in
scoring position and then the single on
jonathan india nice secondary lead
and that helmet has no chance of staying
on that hair so it's a one-run ball game
the tight run at sega base the go-ahead
runner at first and schrock will be the
hitter runner's on the move
schrock looks at a fastball and gallon
strands two for the reds get one back
and after four it's 3-2 diamondback we
go to the bottom of the sixth inning
farmer a hard rbi single he's also fly
to center reds have had four hits on the
game
and there is a blast deep left center
field he's back
[Applause]
talked about the one that hangs
that's the one that hangs the previous
slider you saw the depth on it as i
mentioned no one's going to do any
damage and then he gets the slider again
doesn't have the same bite hello bullpen
bye bye
baseball we head to the eighth inning
and andrew young just double switched
into the ball game will be the first
hitter
andrew young gets a fastball hits it
deep to center field and it's gone
andrew young and we're tied at four the
grand slam thursday
the solo shot today 4-4 in cincinnati
wow 94 mile an hour fastball down and
out over the plate that ball got out of
here in a hurry boy he got a fastball
and he was on it
it is hard to compete in conditions like
this you can hear the rain looks like
there might be some hail that's coming
down bouncing off the hat it is a sheet
the 3-2 to carson kelly bases full one
out
he walked in a run five four
diamondbacks haven smith comes in with a
go-ahead run look at tucker barnhart
yelling out to jerry meals the crew
chief who's the second base umpire why
are we still playing
well you can see they are
rolling the tarp out now the tarp
arrives and we hit a rain delay
tonight's game against the reds has been
suspended game will be resumed tomorrow
so the game was uh suspended last night
it was supposed to be continued today it
has been delayed and now it will be
resumed so lucas sims was on the mound
when the game concluded last night the
suspension came in
and he'll be on the bond with the bases
loaded but now the sun is out it is cold
in cincinnati and escobar is the batter
popped up
shading his eyes farmer into foul ground
fears back to his left adjusts and makes
the catch that's a big first out upon a
resuming play
lifted to right winker has it red
and sims gets through it and he just
slammed the palm of his hand against his
glove we go to the bottom of the ninth
grandma come on try and save it the
winker's on the tying run is on base the
winning run will bat
swing in the mids on the curveball
diamondbacks win it five four
one game two days two different uniforms
but they get the win in the opener of
this three-game set in cincinnati